[Music]
well I mean I think that there's this
funny idea that people have that women
have that feminism somehow said that we
can have it all and feminism did not say
that you know I think that the thinking
that you can have every single thing you
want in life is not thinking of a
feminist so thinking of a toddler and
it's not just about women nobody not
anybody can have everything they want
that feminism says you're fully human
you're a full human being as a woman but
the human condition is not getting
everything you want in life so it stands
to reason that would apply to us too I
think that you know there are plenty of
cultures and religions that impress that
upon their you know adherence and I
think that ours at this moment in time
is not one of them I really thought that
it was a worthwhile project to try to be
the protagonist in my own life and that
I wanted to be a writer and I wanted to
be like an adventurer I mean that's
those are the kinds of non-traditional
female lives that I looked up to and
aspired to emulate and I did get to do
that I do get to do that as a writer for
The New Yorker and it's great I love it
but when you what my experience was is
if you start if you decide at 37 I'm
ready to have a family and anything goes
wrong as it did for me you're sort of
that you've kind of run out the clock
and then you don't get to do that then
that then you've missed that part of
life that field of experience so I think
that that's what I was trying to say is
that just you know I think that there's
sort of a design flaw in the human
female animal that like at
we the moment you feel you finally might
be mature enough to be equipped to take
care of a person other than your own
self that is the moment when your body
says I'm out and it's not the same for
men that is a woman's cross to bear a
couple months after it happened I was at
my friend's 40th birthday party and I
was talking to this woman and she said
are you the Arielle who all the bad
things happened to and I my first
thought was how many orioles do you know
and but then of course I said yes I I am
that Arielle and she said well
everything happens for a reason
and my response to that was you know
like well everything happens for several
reasons like I'm out here talking to you
because I left the living room and came
on to the porch so that's the reason
this has happened I mean everything of
course happens for a reason and other
many a bunch of reasons what people
really mean when they say everything
happens for a reason is everything
happens for your own good which I just
think is an incredibly ludicrous lullaby
to sing to yourself I think that I think
the more important thing it's not like
Oh everything happens for a reason it's
like we'll know everything happens like
once something's happened you know so
for example when I was like in the thick
of my grief I would wake up in the
morning and I would just feel like no
mm-hmm this is unacceptable
I don't accept this I I don't agree to
this reality I don't want my son to be
dead it's not cool with me I mean I
think it's I think that's you know it's
one of the stages of grief right it's
denial or bargaining I suppose that is
anyway whatever the point is that I
don't know that everything happens for a
reason but once something's happened
the sooner you admit it
like the sooner the sooner you admit
like whether I accept it or not this is
the truth so I better find a way to
surrender to it
I mean I think that's the trick really